And now to you, Scoutmaster.
So you know, it's not the act of making a podcast that makes you crazy.
Podcasting doesn't make you crazy
Now, it just makes your craziness a little more accessible to the rest of the world.
How about that?
Hey, this is podcast number 81.
Music.
Hey, welcome back to the Scoutmaster podcast.
This is Clark Green. I'm back.
How about that?
Yeah, We had a big trip and about three weeks of traveling and scouting.
Guess where
There's a little musical hint.
You got it yet.
That's right.
Yes, we were in the wonderful country of Switzerland,
at Kondersteg International Scout Center for a week with a group of our Scouts,
And what a wonderful experience.
That was preceded by a week of vacation with my lovely wife in the same town in Kondersteg,
And that was preceded by a week at summer camp.
So, basically, I've been pretty much out of circulation for the past three or four weeks
in between all of the traveling and scouting that we got to do,
And I'm just so happy to be back home.
Well, you know, pretty happy to be back home.
I had to leave some pretty marvelous places behind,
But home is a pretty marvelous place too.
First of all, let's see,
Now that we're back, we got a lot of cleaning up to do.
First, a couple of abject apologies.
That's right,
I had some podcasts and posts and things like that ready to go out
and programmed to go out over the time I was gone.
The posts did pretty well,
The podcast, oh my. I put a couple of phantom podcasts out.
What I had hoped to be able to do was, in the time that I was traveling,
be able to, you know, put together a couple of quick podcasts for you,
And I had things set up
Well, it didn't work out,
And so there's been a number of you have been writing in about the fact
that the podcast seems to have disappeared from iTunes
and that you couldn't download the podcast,
And I really apologize for all the frustration.
But, like I said, you know I was away,
I didn't have web access
And actually, to tell you the God's honest truth,
I wasn't all that concerned because, man,
if you've never been to Switzerland, wow, what a place,
Just an incredible country with.
We were in the heart of the Bernese Alps
And you know, you just kind of wake up in a state of slack-jawed awe
every day and you get to do some marvelous hikes
and meet some wonderful people.
Kondersteg International Scout Center has been operating since the 1920s
and it is a center for scouts from all over the world
who come and visit during the summer- and all throughout the year,
but mainly during the summer-
And just to participate in some scout brotherhood
and to take in the wonderful sights around the town of Kondersteg.
We met scouts from the United Kingdom.
We met scouts from Russia-
How about that
Russia?
We met scouts from Portugal, from Ireland,
from an incredible number of countries all around the world-
Brazil,
And what a wonderful, wonderful time.
So here's a couple of quick takeaways for you.
Scouting is still a relevant, wonderful worldwide movement
and the people that you get to meet are just wonderful folks.
We all share much more in common than we do in the way of differences.
So the world is sometimes a troubled and difficult place,
but as long as there are scouts in it,
there's going to be that bright point of light out there.
The other big takeaway that I'll repeat at Infinatum
is that if you set your mind to it,
if your scouts get excited and motivated about doing something-
anything from a big international trip like this
just to, you know, a weekend camping trip- you can do it.
It can happen,
And it also takes us a little vision,
a little leadership on the part of your scouts
and it will happen.
And I don't normally call out my scouts by name
or refer to them personally,
but I've got to tell you
the crew chief that we selected for this particular trip,
Robert H,
and is just a wonderful leader
and he put a lot of energy into it
and I think he had the best time of all the scouts
that attended that trip.
So kudos to you, Robert H,
for having done a wonderful job in making that trip happen
for your fellow scouts and for us adults too.
So I'll have much more- probably more than you want to hear-
to say about that whole thing in future- podcasts
and blog posts and things.
but let's get down to brass tacks.
I've got interviews lined up for this fall
with authors and things.
I've got gear reviews
and hopefully within the next week or so,
we'll see the return of our weekly caption contest
on Tuesdays.
I got lots of nice messages of welcome home.
Thanks, folks.
And oh, I should mention
I have an interview in the works
about the Journey to Excellence program.
Now, if you're not familiar with the Journey to Excellence program
or you haven't heard of it,
well, get on the BSA national website.
search for Journey to Excellence
and you'll see that it is the new unit evaluation program
that promises to actually be one of
a very revolutionary tool
for scout leaders to use
to work on their unit effectiveness.
I have interview in the works with one of the volunteers
who developed this program at a national level,
and so what I would like to do
in preparation for that interview
is hear your questions or comments
about the Journey to Excellence program.
I can pass those questions and comments onto him
and see what we can learn.
I heard from Kent Jennings,
who is from South Africa.
He says I'm a member of the Orion rover crew
and one of our rovers attended
Kent Jennings.
Great to see you advertising scouting.
I enjoy your blog.
It's great to see others who are willing to write
Yours and scouting Kent Jennings.
Well, thanks, Kent.
I did not run into anybody from South Africa
while I was at Kent Jennings,
at least not that I can remember,
but I certainly appreciate you being in touch.
Thundering Thor got back in touch.
He said thank you for giving the National Park Service programs
for scouts some well-deserved publicity
And if you missed that, it's a blog post.
There are national park service programs
that recognize scouts and give you some activities
that you can do while visiting national parks.
Thor goes on to say it's a wonderful program,
not only for Boy Scouts
but for Cub Scouts and Girl Scouts of all levels.
The National Park Service Rangers and personnel
have been helpful and always happy
to lend a hand with our scouts.
The Junior Ranger programs
available at each national park service site
also make for lots of fun.
Thanks again for all you do
And, PS, the Green Bar Bill podcast was awesome.
Well, thank you for being in touch again, Thor.
It's always good to hear from everybody.
So we're going at light with this podcast.
There's a lot of threads to pick up
and things to take care of,
you know, as well as keeping up with the blog
and the podcast and the scout troop,
So you're going to have to be patient with me.
I did have a recent discussion about discipline
in scouting that I think be useful to talk about
for a little bit,
And we're going to do that in scout master's ship
in seven minutes or less,
which is the biggest fib going.
as far as the podcast is concerned,
I think we'll probably go over seven minutes,
but hey,
And that's going to do it for the podcast this time.
So let's get started, shall we
Scout master's ship in seven minutes or less.
This coming April marks something over 30 years
as a scout leader, as an adult volunteer,
And it's been a wonderful ride.
But there are always challenges
and there are difficulties,
and some of these surround discipline in scouting.
I mean, we're dealing with boys
at a very formative part
during a very formative part of their lives,
who are pushing limits and trying and testing
and doing things,
And we do have to have some kind of discipline
and we have to be able to exercise discipline
and to address situations as they arise.
This is not, you know,
one of the fun parts of being a scout leader.
It can be very daunting and frustrating
and difficult
and discouraging,
But if we're prepared ahead of time,
like most things,
we're going to be able to meet these challenges head-on
and to dispatch them in a way
that is both positive for our scouts
and is not too trying for ourselves.
This subject came up
in a little back-and-forth discussion I had
via Facebook
and somebody had asked me a couple of questions
about a discipline problem they were having
and we got to talking back-and-forth
and I want to take a moment
to treat the idea of discipline
and scouting with some broad underlying concepts-
And if you're familiar with the podcast,
that's one of my favorite phrases-
broad underlying concepts.
I can give you some specifics
and some suggestions,
but what you really need
is you need to be grounded in the
broad underlying concepts.
that will help you dispense
and deal with and
make discipline
in your scout unit
a viable
and useful and positive,
positive thing.
I read a recent posting
at Ask Andy
and Andy is a scout commissioner
who has kind of an advice column
at the United States Scouts
Service Project website.
Very easy to find:
Just Google Ask Andy
and Scouts
and you'll find his columns
and there's several years of them there.
but he had a couple of statements
that I think are very useful.
so my tip of the campaign had to Andy.
He said this:
in the BSA adult unit level,
volunteers
may guide scouts in establishing
a troop culture
of order and correct behavior.
However,
punishment in any form
is not a part of the scouting experience.
The absence of overt punishment
does not mean suggest or imply
that actions have no consequences.
All actions have consequences.
They're commensurate with the nature
of the action.
The scout master is ultimately responsible
for the scout's behavior and comportment.
If the scout master is unsuccessful
in finding the best in a boy
and bringing it out,
then he can ask for help.
If the scout master is unable
to understand the current behavior,
they ought to be replaced with someone
who can fulfill the responsibilities
of the position.
That kind of helps identify
some of the concepts
of discipline in scouting.
I'm going to keep hammering
on one key statement:
Punishment
is just not a part
of the scouting experience.
Some of you may not like
that particular statement
and may not think that you can
maintain discipline without the threat
of punishment, but you can,
And we're going to talk about how
We want to remember that. discipline
means to teach.
It has similar roots
to the word disciple.
Discipline does not mean
exclusively to punish.
Effective discipline is consistent
and requires patience.
Effective discipline doesn't stifle
scouts. It gives them
dependable foundation
from which to grow and mature,
Because we have to remember what their job is.
You're dealing with boys,
if you're in a scout troop,
who are between the ages of 10 and a half
and 17..
Part of their job at this age
is to find boundaries.
The way they find boundaries
is they walk right up to them
and then they jump over them.
They test you,
and they're not testing you personally.
they're seeing if the world
is going to live up to these promises
And because they're not
testing you personally,
it's important that
areas of discipline
be divorced from your
personal emotional reactions.
I mean, you're going to have some
predictable emotional reactions:
You're going to get angry,
You're going to get frustrated.
Oftentimes you'll be embarrassed,
You'll be sad,
You'll be disappointed,
But these are not very helpful
emotions when it comes to discipline.
Now, if you're listening
to this podcast and you're a volunteer
scout leader, chances are
very good, chances are
that you're also a parent,
And when I say that your child's
testing of boundaries
and things like that is not personal,
you may not believe me,
Because they know how to make it
personal, don't they?
And it can be very, very harmful.
It can be really, really upsetting.
The thing is that, as a parent
and as a volunteer
scout leader and having observed
all of these processes for a good many years,
there ain't nothing special about
your boy or your daughter,
because all of them,
all of them-
do this. It's part of their job,
And
I think understanding that
helps us divorce
our reaction
to what they do
from our emotions.
We need to connect actions
with consequences.
That's important.
There are two types
of consequences to any action.
One is natural
and one
is logical.
Natural consequences are automatic
and they really don't require our intervention.
I'll give you a simple example.
If I was told
to bring rain gear with me
on a camping trip
and I don't bring it and it rains and I get wet,
that's a natural consequence.
If somebody says to me,
do not touch that, it is hot,
and I touch it and I get burned,
that's a natural consequence.
There are also
logical consequences,
and those logical consequences
are something that we may impose.
and you may think
that I am trying to avoid
the word punish,
but I'm not trying to avoid it, because
what I'm talking about
is not aimed at
punishing behavior,
It's aimed at correcting it.
So let's talk about that
for a moment. It's not aimed
at punishing behavior,
It's aimed at correcting it.
So part of discipline is about
correcting wrong behavior,
but part of discipline is also
reinforcing good actions.
Whenever it's possible, as scout leaders,
I think we need to rely on
natural consequences
and we let scouts deal with the fallout of their actions.
We don't rescue them
when it's not an issue
of physical safety or propriety.
We don't rescue them
If they make
bad plans
and it's not going to threaten their health or safety.
we should let them
deal with the fallout
and do it in a very
understanding way,
and not lord it over them
and tell them: I told you so,
but you know, just say, hey,
been there. this is really frustrating,
isn't it? You didn't plan very well
and now you're really frustrated.
So what's our way out of the situation?
In the best case scenario,
natural consequences run their course
without much intervention from adult leadership at all,
Other than
to, you know, reflect and
discuss on the situation and see if we can turn it into
some kind of a teachable moment.
When the actions of
scouts create an immediate threat to health or safety,
those actions have to be stopped immediately,
And then
scouts need to
work with the logical consequences
of their bad actions.
Now, the discussion
that spurred this part
of the podcast
surrounded the improper use of matches
on camping trips.
I mean, what would you do if you found
freshly burnt matches and match books in the area
you were camping?
And this is obviously a situation
where we can't allow the natural
consequences of the actions to do the job
Because somebody
or something
could get burned, and that's really just
not an option.
Step one
is to take this issue
to the patrol leaders council
and ask them what the natural
consequences of sex actions would be.
Tell us
we found these matches,
match books, Somebody's playing with matches,
Somebody's not using them responsibly.
You know.
tell me what
the possibilities are here.
Tell me what could happen if we allow this
to go on.
And you know they're
going to think about it a little bit.
They're going to come up with well, somebody could set
fire, Somebody could burn themselves,
Somebody could threaten everyone's safety with
this, And you know these are
fairly self-evident things. but you don't
want to preach at your patrol
leaders council. What you want to do
is you want to poke at them with some questions
and get them to identify things
as self-evident as they might be,
And you want them to be able
to put these things into words.
Ask them what they think logical
consequences of the actions should be,
And remember that punishment
is not an option.
Now I've been all around the block
with the whole punishment thing,
because our natural reaction,
our natural reaction
to bad actions,
is to default to this
punishment model.
You know
well, hey, you didn't wear your neck a chip
giving me 10 push ups.
You didn't do thus and so,
or you did thus and so, so now you're going to be
grounded, or you're going to be denied privileges
and you're going to be
dismissed from the troop, or you're going to be
suspended, or
there's all of these elaborate
plans that we draw up and things
that we think through for stuff like that.
but I want you to try
thinking about discipline.
absent
the option of punishing,
Does your patrol leaders council
need to discover
who the individual actor was
in this situation?
Do they need to figure out who was playing
with matches?
This is a pretty important question,
because how is this going to play out
and is it really going to be all that useful?
How are they going to make that happen?
Coercing a confession
with the threat of punishment
is not an option for us
in scouting, and I got to tell you
it doesn't really work.
Our gut reaction is usually
identifying and punishing an individual
for some kind of bad action.
We do this out of a sense of fairness,
but more often than not
that sense of fairness
gets misplaced.
We can also do this out of a sense
of frustration and anger,
and we have to be careful about that.
Scouting is a good opportunity
for all of us to learn that
the failing of an individual
is often- now
not always, but often the failure
of the group to support and inform them.
I got to tell you, in a situation like this
and many associated situations,
if the bad actor doesn't immediately
identify themselves,
locating the individual
and getting them to fess up
can be hugely counterproductive.
I've
tried it.
I've tried it. It doesn't
work very well.
I refuse to be an investigator
and I refuse to be a policeman.
I don't have the training skill,
natural ability for any of that.
I'm not going to try to interview
witnesses and try and figure things out.
I really don't have
that ability.
When we attempt to identify
an individual bad actor, everything usually
comes to a stop. We find the matches,
we find the burnt match books,
whatever. Get the troop together.
we say, okay, fellas, there's a problem
here, somebody's been lighting matches
and I need to know who it is,
and we're going to stand
right here until somebody
tells me who it is.
well, now you've
so stigmatized that
that
you've created some real disincentive
for the person to come forward.
because they're not going to come forward,
you're going to get even more frustrated
and a little more angry and then you might. hey,
if we can't make this happen right now,
if somebody doesn't step up and tell me who it is.
we're going to pack up everything and we're going to go home.
I've been there before,
you know.
let me, let me take a minute. I don't want to get too
diverted from the subject, but let me take a minute here.
I'm not trying to judge you.
I'm not trying to judge your actions, your feelings,
the way that you do things, the way that you raise your children.
what I'm trying to do
is point out some of the mistakes
that I've made along the way.
if this connects with you, that's fine.
you know, I'm not trying to make out
that I am the
all wise
wizard here, because I'm not.
I've made these mistakes
and I still make them.
if we get that group of scouts together and we try
and coerce a confession out of an individual,
you can see what's happening. right, I'm up in the ante.
hey, we're going to pack up and go home
if nobody steps forward.
I've had it. I'm not dealing with you guys anymore.
that could, in a very small percentage
of instances, maybe
get somebody to step forward, but that
generally is not going to happen. you're going to pack up and go home.
and now you've
up the ante even more
because you've packed up and gone home. so the next time
we get together with scouts- and this has already gone through
the troop committee and all the parents have discussed it
and the scouts have discussed it-
you're going to say we need to find out who
lit those matches, that scouts not coming
forward now because
the ante is too high,
the price to pay is too high
now. if we approach this in a different way,
if we say someone playing
with matches means that we haven't done a very good
job as a troop and a patrol in teaching safety,
ask
the patrol leaders council
what they think a logical consequence of that should be.
maybe they should voluntarily
forgo all fire lighting privileges
for a given time for everybody in the whole troop.
that doesn't seem fair,
but if you think about it,
this connects
all the individuals together.
hey, these are important things. this is an important thing
and we have to obey
the rules and regs around this
and if one of us isn't doing it,
that could mean that
we're in some trouble here.
perhaps the patrol leaders council
will plan
a fire safety session for the next meeting
for everyone.
if you encourage group responsibility,
you're going to get responsible scouts individually
and as a group.
if you punish individuals,
you'll end up more
with this kind of every man for himself mentality
than a sense of cooperative responsibility
and
progressively more challenging and difficult things we do
in the outdoors.
you've got to have cooperative responsibility.
individual responsibility-
absolutely important,
absolutely has to be
an aspect
of what we do in scouting.
but cooperative group responsibility-
also
incredibly important,
and they need to be able to tie those two concepts together.
I can't be all taken care of
and set up and
safe and dry
and watch as my fellow scout
is out there, wet and unsafe
and not doing well,
because we all
need to stick together.
I think when individuals are punished or sanctioned,
it has
a smaller chance of helping them
learn anything other than shame,
other than feeling ashamed
and,
you know, sometimes in a way that
is kind of irreparable.
it also makes the results of admitting
fault
so unpleasant
that we end up placing the wrongdoer on one side
and the rest of their friends
and scouting and the adults and the committee
and all the parents on the other,
and I just don't think that that is
really very helpful.
and when we're talking about individuals,
we've got to.
I'm going to go back to something that
Andy wrote
in the same column.
he says:
yes, a scout may do a bad thing.
that's behavior.
but when we call him
a liar if he lied
or we call him a fire bug if he lit matches,
we're cutting to his very nature
and branding his character
rather than dealing
with the inappropriate behavior.
I'll add to that
that we need to once again be aware
of our emotional reactions
and that we don't let it
inform our actions
and keep upping the ante
on these individuals.
now, what I've described is,
you know,
certainly a serious
problem
and one way of looking at it.
it's a reasonably serious problem with the matches
and you know
that could turn into something very serious
indeed.
it's not necessarily,
you know, the top tier
difficulties and serious problems that I've had
as a scout leader.
I have
rarely had to deal with the logical consequences
of an individual's behavior
in scouting
that resulted in them having to deal with the police.
like I say,
not to tempt fate knocked wood
that I haven't had to deal with that very much,
basically, twice
in the 30 years of working as a scout leader,
both times the offenses
were only kind of tangentially related
to scouting activities.
they didn't occur
on a troop outing or at a meeting,
they occurred outside of those things.
now, when I was made aware of the incidents
and the charges,
I did have to take some action.
I mean, I couldn't ignore them
because in both cases
the actions of the individual scouts
resulted in charges that could have been
detrimental to our scouts
if they were repeated during an outing or a meeting.
I can tell you that
one was assault related
and one was drug related.
it's a serious problem for a young man
and in those two instances
you know we had to look at that
and say: well,
until this gets resolved,
we're going to have to ask you to stay away
from scouts for the time being.
it's not that we think you're guilty,
it's not that we think you're innocent,
it's not that we really think anything about you at all,
but you've gotten yourself into a bit of a pickle here,
and until it's resolved
by the authorities,
there's really not a whole lot we're going to be able to do.
in both cases, after consulting with the troop committee
chair,
the scout was suspended from activities with the troop
until everything was resolved
by the authorities,
and then the
next step would be the scout to meet
with the troop committee and map a way forward
if he was going to continue in scouting.
one of them did
and one of them hasn't so far,
doors still open.
our overall goal in dealing with these incidents
was to preserve the safety of our scouts,
the privacy
of the offending scout
and his family,
and to give him
a road back to redeem themselves
after the authorities have made their determinations
more routine. discipline problems
get dealt with on a case to case basis.
we don't have a policy or a plan that describes
offenses and consequences.
we're informed
only by the scout. oath and law.
that is
the gold standard for behavior
and discipline.
I gotta say, if you have such a written policy
that describes
punishments,
that
has this kind of tiered approach
to discipline problems,
that includes you know well, you're going to have a conference with the scout master,
then the senior patroller,
blah, blah, blah.
that might be helpful
in some respects. but I gotta tell you,
consider,
every serious discipline problem is unique
because it's coming from an individual
and it will ultimately need to be addressed
on an individual basis.
if you're hemmed in by a policy statement
that you've made,
you may not have the latitude to act
in the best interest of everybody involved.
just a little bit of advice there.
this is a big subject,
it's a tough subject
and, like I say, there's lots of emotions
and difficulties and questions
and morality and things involved in it.
but just to review,
when we encounter
discipline problems in scouting,
we need to
divorce our emotional reaction from it.
we need to understand that discipline
is not punishment,
discipline is teaching.
we can turn these difficulties
most of the time-
not always, but most of the time-
we can turn them into something positive
and something that is, instead of a tool
for beating somebody down,
for building them up,
instead of an incident
that's going to sap the morale
away from our troop,
we can build it into something
that bolsters
and broadens the morale of the troop.
we can
save individuals from
being stigmatized and castigated
and cast out of
their circle of friends, sometimes
for mistakes
that they are going to make.
they're all going to make them.
it's going to be your child one day.
it's going to happen.
so this is
a pretty broad discussion,
broad underlying concepts.
I would love to hear your thoughts
and reflections on the subject
and I'll tell you how to get in touch with me
in just a moment.
music.
well, thanks for listening.
it sure is good to be back
and to be putting the Scoutmaster podcast together again.
here's how you can keep in touch.
you can read the Scoutmaster blog
at scoutmastercgcom,
and when you do
subscribe to the Scoutmaster newsletter,
which is a monthly digest
of the Scoutmaster blog and podcast
with some great scouting resources
around a monthly theme,
and every newsletter includes a giveaway
from one of our affiliate sponsors-
music,
music.
you can subscribe to the Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes
and when you do feel free to leave a comment
or review or rating-
that's right- you really can subscribe
to the Scoutmaster podcast on iTunes. I promise
once this one is up,
everything will be better.
you can also call
and leave a voicemail, comment or question,
and this is the number you call:
484-734-0002.
you'll get a voicemail
message from yours truly
and an invitation to leave a voicemail
question
or comment or joke
or song or whatever
for inclusion in the Scoutmaster podcast
music.
you can also follow us at
the Scoutmaster blog on Facebook
or Scoutmaster CG
on Twitter.
you can email me,
Clark Green, with your comments and questions
at
Scoutmaster CG.
that's Scoutmaster letter C,
letter G
at Verizonnet:
Scoutmaster CG
at Verizonnet.
the Scoutmaster blog
and the Scoutmaster podcast are not
official publications of the Boy Scouts of America.
Heaven, just the Betsy.
no, no, no.
nor are they endorsed or sponsored by the Boy Scouts of America.
hey, I don't even know
if they know I'm out here or not.
nope, it's just me talking into a microphone
trying to lend a hand to scout leaders
and perhaps have a bit of fun along the way.
I hope you had fun.
music
and finally, before we go,
let's hear from the founder of Scouting,
Sir Robert Baden-Powell.
Sir Robert, good luck to you
and good camping.
why? thank you, sir?
thanks again for listening and until next time,
music,
music.